des travaux qui ont débuté sur la n191
les équipes d'yves d'une fibre vont
bientôt relier les communes
d'allainville et de parler doivent ils à
la fibre ce sont les deux dernières
villes concernées par les chantiers
divine fibre les défis autour de la
ville et par et doivent il sait que ce
sont liées à des bourgs mais il ya
également des hameaux qu'il faut aller
chercher donc on est déjà et en chercher
un sur paris doit ville qui s'appelle
obvie les huit qui est déjà ouvert
mais par contre il ya aussi pas mal de
fermes isolées et donc là on a des
travaux de génie civil sur sur également
plus ou moins kilomètres pour aller
chercher différents hameaux avec ce
dernier chantier ils viennent fibre aura
équipé 150 communes près de quatre ans
de travaux qui représente 5000 km de
câbles et 200 km de tranchées le
territoire yvelinois augmente en terme
de population en termes de maison donc
il ya des nouveaux collectifs il ya des
nouvelles maisons qui se construisent et
toutes ces maisons là où tous ses
nouveaux collectifs il faut continuer à
les rendre éligibles à la fibre donc on
a aujourd'hui un pas mal de chantiers
qui sont en cours dire que les
promoteurs nous consultent pour savoir
comment ils peuvent raccorder leurs
programmes immobiliers à la fibre
optique compte tenu que orange ne
propose plus de cuivre dans ces nouveaux
bâtiments donc pour que les gens est
internet c'est la fibre rien du tout les
déploiements aujourd'hui de 95 % a
débuté en avril 2010 neuf du côté des
vêtements et de sept autres communes